I mean really really basic honestly like
you know we you me this is so stupid but
it's hard for people that do I realize
reusing things I mean I remember growing
I was like yeah grew up in a really poor
family and everything had three uses
before it got broke away it's just like
it's just mind-boggling to me like how
disposable things are right now so
that's like one way but one thing of
looking at it you know we do need to
really demand of like in our workplaces
that our you know Carter's do recycle
lead many of them don't which is
atrocious if you ask me and like
sometimes you ask like folks like
everybody's want to switch out their
light balls what you ask people do they
the answer would be no but so why don't
you switch out your light bulbs for the
love of God but also I think the biggest
thing and this is actually probably more
micro or macro rather is understanding
that you know in doing what you can in
whatever capacity you have to understand
that especially if you're living a more
privileged lifestyle that more there are
more communities out there that aren't
so when you bust your toilet when you
throw something away it doesn't just go
away it really does impact somebody
else's community and if we thought about
that when we did that when we if we use
an opportunity to talk about policies
and what that means you know for folks
that you know are on the other end of
that pipeline I think that's also really
helpful and talking about the fact that
all of our decisions actually have an
impact on somebody else and usually
there are poor people according to more
power